c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france mène
4 à la une ce soir la date butoir de
l'opposition malienne le cadre des
partis pour une transition réussie a
annoncé ce jeudi qu'il ne reconnaîtra
plus les autorités de transition à
partir du 25 mars prochain pourquoi
cette date quelle conséquence nous
étions en direct tout à l'heure de
bamako avec son président modibo soumaré
la manifestation de plusieurs centaines
de magistrats et d'avocats en tunisie il
dénonce la dissolution du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature par le
président queille cède reportage de nos
correspondants à suivre enfin nous irons
au burundi où les défenseurs des droits
de l'homme hausse le ton il reproche à
l'union européenne d'avoir repris ses
aises au burundi et de financer un
pouvoir qui piétinent les droits humains
les détails dans ce journal
le cadre des partis pour une transition
réussie qui rassemble plusieurs dizaines
de mouvements politiques posent en
quelque sorte un ultimatum au pouvoir
malien avec une date butoir le 25 mars à
compter de ce jour ses membres ne
reconnaîtront plus les autorités de
transition modibo soumaré président du
cadre des partis pour une transition
réussie était notre invité tout à
l'heure il nous expliquait que cette
décision était une main tendue et non
pas un geste hostile qui pourraient
rompre tout dialogue écouter
et sfr en ag de l'élection et d'un ciel
à paris du werther février donc de chez
moi et le nouveau président était
prêté serment le 25 mars donc nous avons
et après beaucoup d'échangés après
plusieurs mois déjà des propositions
dont on dit qu'il fallait qu'on soit et
à partir du budget de supplanter à
partir du 25 mars et qui nous proposons
à la place de ce vide juridique une
tradition match avec un imprimé miss
côte en ciel et adapter un gourmand
inclusif et qu' une proposition de très
neuf mois des trahisons pour drainer des
élections ont les moyens puissent
choisir mes dirigeants alors ne craignez
vous pas de duke reid
la division est de perdre le soutien de
la population qui semble en tout cas en
partie derrière les autorités au pouvoir
nous aussi nous sommes les autorités
l'ensemble des règles et d'autorité pour
l'application et du programme de la
tradition pour le reste et l'achat de la
transition on sent une autorité pour
l'ordination d'élections transparentes
et crédibles et derrière londres ont
tendu une main justement pour qu'on
puisse dialoguer trouver les solutions
d'avoir proposé un programme crédible et
réaliste et à la cedeao pour mes wc
cette action qui font beaucoup plus de
mal aux populations que les dirigeants
et de démence qui est un grand consensus
de confisquer réunies et il n'y en a
créé autour des actions de la république
et organisé des élections avec tout le
monde et qu'il puisse traduire le moment
cette attaque au bénin 5 cartes fort et
si un soldat ont été tués et dix
personnes blessées dans une embuscade
mardi dans un parc naturel du nord du
pays parmi eux un français âgé de 50 ans
il aurait été victime d'une attaque
terroriste le parquet national anti
terroristes français a annoncé jeudi
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
assassinat en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
cette mobilisation pour la sauvegarde de
la justice en tunisie plusieurs
centaines de magistrats et d'avocats ont
protesté ce jeudi sur les marches du
palais de justice à tunis il dénonce la
dissolution du csm le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature par le président kaïs
aed reportage de lilia blaise et âme
depuis
le palais de justice de tunis est
l'épicentre de la colère des avocats et
des juges ils protestent ensemble contre
la décision de quel seuil est de
dissoudre le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
l'organe qui nomme les magistrats
[Applaudissements]
la justice ne peut être réformé que dans
une période politiquement stable et
apaisée et dans un cadre constitutionnel
qui garantit un dialogue inclusif
malheureusement avec cette décision
price a aidé a choisi l'escaladé est une
solution de facilité qui risque de
détruire le pays kai ces aides reproche
à l'institution sa partialité et sa
corruption il avait dénoncé son
obstruction à l'enquêté sur les
assassinats des opposants de gauche
chokri belaid et mohamed brahmi en 2013
faux selon cette juge pour qui ces aides
instrumentalise ces dossiers politiques
le csm n'intervient pas dans le court
des dossiers dans les tribunaux et c'est
qu'entre même l'indépendance de la
magistrature et des magistrats le csm
gvt les carrières des magistrats laisser
complètement
différent la société civile monte au
créneau et dénonce des mesures prises
dans un état d'exception sans garde-fou
durant une période d'exception des
institutions d'état doivent être
maintenues notamment le csn qui est le
groupe plus grands piliers du système
démocratique tunisien le plus grand
garant de la continuité de la démocratie
et la garantie des libertés
individuelles
et collectives en tunisie face à cette
levée de boucliers qu'elle sayed semblé
faire marche arrière mercredi et disait
vouloir préserver le csm avant de
rétropédaler à nouveau et de le
dissoudre jeudi 10 février en attendant
la révision de la loi une instance
provisoire devrait être créé pour le
remplacer
l'onu continuera de soutenir le premier
ministre libyen des amis de beille bas
et ce malgré la désignation ce jeudi
d'un autre premier ministre par le
parlement de tobrouk il s'agit de
l'influent ex-miss de l'intérieur fait
tryba chara je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction du porte-parole du parlement
tobrouk il répondait aux questions de
théo ferme juillet sur france 24 en
arabe écouter aux hackers de vianne je
confirme que c'est au parlement de
prendre la décision oui les nations
unies aucun pays n'a le droit de
s'immiscer dans les affaires internes de
lundi au gouvernement
bien qu'aucun acteur quel qu'il soit n'a
le droit de dicter sa décision au
parlement surtout après la désignation
par le parlement de bachar a trop
commode à radio l'onu qui appelle par
ailleurs les dirigeants libyens à s'unir
à se mettre d'accord écouter le
décryptage d'antoine mariotti vous avez
un pouvoir qui le gouvernement quitte à
tripoli dans l'ouest du pays et dans
l'est du pays vous avez ce fameux
parlement de tobrouk web était pris
cette décision aujourd'hui qui très
proche du maréchal haftar on entendu on
sait que ces dernières années il ya eu
des affrontements extrêmement violents
entre l'est et entre l'ouest et depuis
un an il y avait ce gouvernement donc
d'abdelhamid débat qui a été parrainé
par l'onu qui lui a renouvelé sa
confiance aujourd'hui et qui étaient
censés bien sûr une transition jusqu'aux
élections du mois de décembre mais ces
élections n'ont jamais eu lieu elles ont
été reportés sine aidiez on n'a toujours
pas de date est donc aujourd'hui bien ce
parlement de tobrouk qui est opposé
aussi politiquement à ce gouvernement de
tripoli est bien décidé de passer en
force et de délires de choisir et bien
son premier ministre qui est censé selon
heureux et bien remplacer beiba qui lui
ne l'entend pas de cette oreille
puisqu'il a redit mardi qu'il était hors
de question qu'il cède le pouvoir à
quelqu'un qui n'a pas été élu
directement dans les urnes et donc il
était toujours légitime tant qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'élections et d'ailleurs
l'onu dans une déclaration a dit
renouveler quand je voulais dit son
soutien de débats mais a aussi dit que
le parlement de tobrouk fera peut-être
bien de se concentrer sur le fait de
trouver une solution politique et une
date pour ces fameuses élections
les réactions de l'ouganda après le
jugement rendu par la cour
internationale de justice la plus haute
juridiction de l'onu ordonne à kampala
de verser 325 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts à la république
démocratique du congo pour son invasion
de l'est du pays il y a deux décennies
l'ouganda estime injuste et erronée le
jugement de la cour cette somme fixée
mercredi reste loin des 11 milliards de
dollars réclamés par kinshasa
des défenseurs des droits de l'homme
burundais reproche à l'union européenne
d'avoir repris son aide au burundi pour
eu lieu finance un pouvoir qui piétinent
les droits humains l'ue avait suspendu
en deux 1016 les appuis financiers
direct à l'administration burundaise
pour sanctionner des violences
meurtrières dans le pays wassim cornette
c'est un véritable soulagement la
décision de l'union européenne de mettre
fin aux sanctions sur le pays a été
accueillie avec bonheur à bujumbura et
au delà je vois que cette misère jays
d'azé moment où on l'abordé d'azéma
trait aux portes là haut
depuis 2016 les appuis financiers
européens au burundi avaient été
suspendues afin de sanctionner les
violences provoquées par la crise
politique pour le directeur du port de
la capitale c'est le retour d'une
période d'espoir c est une image et qui
nous attend en d1 mais elle je marque et
les nerfs de cette décision gèle de se
ressaisir et de l'arrivée et sans
condition mais tout le monde n'est pas
du même avis de nombreuses ong ainsi que
des acteurs politiques de l'opposition
ont critiqué cette décision pour eux il
n'y a eu aucune amélioration notable sur
le plan politique est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut dire que
que l'on est dans une situation vraiment
confortable quels droits de l'homme
l'autre il y a notamment des
disparitions forcées toujours qu'ils
sont eux qui s'observe lorsqu'il y à des
arrestations abusives
lorsqu'il y à tout ce qui touche feeling
avec l'injustice d'assaut pays les états
unis avaient déjà lever leurs sanctions
en novembre dernier estimant que la
situation dans le pays avait
suffisamment changé
c'est dans un contexte économique
fragilisé par deux ans de pandémie de
mécontentement un croissant que le
président sud africain à cyril ramaphosa
prononce son discours annuel sur l'état
de la nation il le fera à la mairie du
cap et non au parlement lieu
traditionnel de cette allocution
allocution solennelle un incendié en
janvier la correspondance au cap en
caroline du lait c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'afrique du sud
qu'une rentrée parlementaire ne se fait
pas au parlement vous savez que le
bâtiment avait été incendiée début
janvier bien il faudra sans doute
plusieurs mois peut-être même plusieurs
années pour le reconstruire alors le
gouvernement a décidé de faire la
cérémonie à la mairie du cap qui est
aussi un bâtiment important car c'est là
que nelson mandela a fait sa première
adresse aux sud africains après sa
libération donc on a essayé de faire
comme d'habitude avec la parade
militaire avec les 21 coups de canon
avec les honneurs au chef de l'état et
puis bien sûr un très long discours du
chef de l'état pour cette rentrée
parlementaire un discours qui a touché à
tout à l'économie au social au
changement climatique
mais ce qu'on retiendra c'est son
message contre la corruption un message
très fort il a estimé que le parquet
était désormais prêt pour juger je cite
les réseaux criminels qui ont infiltré
le gouvernement donc allusion aux
rapports contre la la la la capture de
l'appareil d'état aux différents
rapports de corruption qui sont liées
aussi aux équipements covidien avait
quand même pour 15 milliards de rands un
message très fort pour cette rentrée
parlementaire et c'est le message que
les sud africains attendaient
le lauréat du prix francophone de
l'innovation dans les médias étaient
décernés à et les ard c'est ce jeune
média créé en 2020 est basé à goma dans
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo aborde les questions relatives aux
droits humains en format vidéo il
emploie une vingtaine de journalistes
professionnels et amateurs
nos correspondants justin kalumba et
clément bonnes roues les ans rencontré
daniel et cameramans franciska est
encore lycéenne ensemble ils tournent
régulièrement des reportages pour l esaa
rdc malgré son jeune âge franciscain a
déjà un goût prononcé pour le
journalisme engagé
d'abord des femmes et des enfants plus
particulièrement parce que de nos jours
les violences basées sur
les fans les enfants se font à
répétition djoko j'aimerais lutter
contre ces violences ce jour là il
rencontre une femme albinos dans un
quartier populaire de goma l'objectif
récolter son témoignage pour
sensibiliser sur les discriminations
subies par cette minorité est ce que
vous avez à rester voire des injures et
des moqueries de la part de votre
entourage une fois tourné les images
sont envoyées au siège est monté sur
place par une équipe de journalistes
les séquences sont sélectionnés avec
attention car les thématiques abordées
sont sensibles au monde l'image après
avoir après avoir étudié d'abord l'image
voire s'imaginer ne sera pas choquant
voire si l'image n'aura pas
d'effets négatifs sur la victime en
question aussi sur la population et les
1ers décès a été créée en juillet 2020
par esdras tsongo après avoir travaillé
comme pigiste pour left et la bbc il a
lancé son propre média un média innovant
par des jeunes et pour les jeunes les
médias sont accaparés par les contenir
politiques
religieux et alors les jeunes en fait
non pas d' espace où ils peuvent
s'exprimer et nous on a voulu faire à la
vidéo justement parce que la vidéo il ya
de l'émotion la vidéo la profondeur et
c'est pourquoi nous avons voulu faire
des nouveaux et les rdc veut continuer à
se développer et espère atteindre 500
mille abonnés sur youtube d'ici à la fin
de l'année voilà c'est la fin de journal
de l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à vous pour votre
fidélité
restez avec nous l'info continue sur
france 24
[Musique]